russell how are you
sometimes i feel like uh part of the
lockdown is
i'm finding it difficult to motivate
myself i can tell by looking at you
uh are you an expert in body language i
am well i don't think you have to be an
expert in body language to know
that you look like a 90 year old woman
recovering from a stroke
are you okay actually i feel
very optimistic and full of beans and
vim
and vigor and vitality okay good you've
got vim
vitality and vigor you're full of beans
no one's talked that way in 60 years
russell
i love your outfit uh you're wrapped in
towels
it looks like uh you're what's happening
this is
um my most favorite blanket
bequeathed to me by mahatma gandhi not
directly
it was uh someone someone took it in
east london when he visited and uh
you can almost smell the transcendence i
think it's transcended
but anyway it's delicious sometimes when
you use a harsh detergent you can wash
out the transcendence i'm glad you
didn't do that
mistake a lot of people make uh you know
so
we have a lot to talk about first of all
let me make sure to mike
how are you jeff jeff
jeff's just is your producer jeff just
chatting to his family okay
well you try to continue arduously with
your job
i am the i am the opposite of it yes
although i am
someone call jeff and tell him to shut
up here i'll call him right now
jeff we're trying to do an interview
here and we're hearing everything you're
saying
that's because i had my mic on yes i
know i know
over and out oh my god
russell i apologize that was incredibly
unprofessional
not up to the standards that you've set
with the way you're dressing
and the way you're lying i come here
onto your show in the blanket of a
latter-day saint
and you insult me with jeff leaving his
mic on on zoom
a terrible terrible